whoa
I feel like I'm gonna die I know
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Jennifer Lawrence
she's an academy award-winning actress
whose career includes everything from
billion dollar box office franchises to
beloved character performances and films
like Silver Linings Playbook American
Hustle winners bone and many more she
also produces and stars in the brand new
comedy no hard feelings which is set to
release in theaters on June 23rd
Jennifer Lawrence welcome to the show hi
thank you for having me I mean I think
yeah right we'll revisit that here at
the end how are you around spicy food
before we get started I'm okay but I'm
going into this very humble smart smart
I mean I don't think I have that high of
a pain tolerance well I guess we'll find
out today yeah are you ready to get
started yeah sure
thank you
oh we're going right to left yeah that's
very important
okay
let's face it
[Music]
but I would call it like a yeah one I
think that's a fair start so the idea of
an R-rated comedy like no hard feelings
is really appealing to a movie fan like
me especially because so few of them are
made these days what was the Project's
draw for you and how much of a challenge
was it to get a film like this actually
made
so I've known the writer and director of
Gene stubnetsky for years he's a long
long time friend and he showed me this
Craigslist ad that the movie is based on
and we were just dying laughing about
the ad and the idea of parents actually
doing this
you know four years ago I I get the
script and it was the funniest thing
I've ever read so we were like let's go
and I didn't even want to work I wasn't
going to work for a long time and I just
we wanted to make it as soon as possible
and then was there any sort of technique
or original Source material to draw from
for your reaction to getting throat
punched at the Princeton party no that
was something I was really trying to
like kind of taper down I didn't want to
go too big but then you know you are
getting punched in the larynx so that
comes with its own sounds and then the
kind of the panic of of not knowing when
you're going to be able to breathe but
the scariest part was it was a stunt
Shelf
and so we really only had like one take
to get it
um so that was there was a lot of
pressure well you nailed it thank you
well I did two takes we had to put the
Shelf back on
I just realized I should only take one
bite because I don't want to fall before
I quit I mean what am I gonna walk away
like here you're not gonna walk do
people just quit without getting into
Tem
I don't want to lead the witness or I
don't want to you know Cloud anything
because I watched the show but like on
Tick Tock where it's like
right truncated don't see the end well
yeah you know what we've never had a
woman tap out on this show ever in the
history of the show
classic yeah
that is my female producing partner
before I went on she was like you have
to make it you can and we are and I was
like oh my God I do we are so yeah okay
all right
so I imagine one interesting maybe
difficult part of making movies is
working alongside people who have a
different process than your own is there
a type of acting prep that you're most
intrigued by seeing up close and
personal no I mean I would be nervous to
work with somebody who's method because
I would have no idea how to talk to them
right because like do I have to be in
character
that would just like make me nervous but
I don't know I haven't seen another
process that I've been curious about
because you don't really you don't know
about them right all the time is it just
as easy for you to turn that switch off
now as it was early on in your career
it's a really good question I don't know
I had always been you know very on off
on off until I did American Hustle and I
worked with Christian Bale who I noticed
when the camera started rolling and the
crew kind of started preparing like it
was going to be you know 10 seconds or
whatever to action he would kind of
start like getting ready and then I saw
that and was like that seems like a
really good idea and so then I
started to do that
[Music]
I hope I'm like Lord where I'm like
that's a good wing
[Music]
so far
yeah
it's not gonna like like Crescendo not
yet but that's a good instinct to have
by the way because like a lot of times
when people come out here maybe they're
like not used to something like this
they'll bite into it and then off that
like initial you're actually tearing up
did you know that I'm no superhero all
right Jennifer I come in here and I
struggle the exact same way you know and
this one is getting you
well you know maybe I'm just moved yeah
don't just move but no and then you know
I've been doing this for so many years
you know it's like an athlete you know
like slowing down a little bit you know
the aches and pains they kind of they go
on another couple days you know what I
mean never had an ulcer you know
ignorance is bliss you know what I mean
yeah
just don't go to the doctor and then
they can't take my show away you know
wow all men are the same
between losing a tooth swallowing your
nose ring and accidentally getting
struck in the face with a glass what
stands out is the most distressing onset
accident you had while shooting don't
look up
they were both like around Leonardo
DiCaprio which was just like embarrett
like you don't want to go
and spit something that just got snorted
through your sinuses and like and Leo
was like was that your what is that and
I was like it's my nose ring that was
embarrassing but truly having it wasn't
just one tooth because I have veneers
I had a whole section like missing and
it was height of covet so I couldn't go
to the dentist so I had to do all of
don't look up with just a gaping hole in
my mouth Meryl Streep Jonah Hill
Leonardo DiCaprio just everybody I was
like
so I guess I would say the missing tooth
it must be so exciting for a sauce
company to be on your show it is yeah
they get very excited about it this one
is warm
starting to move up a little bit yeah
and it has that kind of like but the
flavor is great I like how sticky it is
damn is that kind of like molasses
finish on it yeah and then this one does
have though that kind of 30 seconds
later kind of hitting clapping sort of
okay yeah I'm starting to kind of feel
it in my eyes yeah yeah me too you know
I was just a wing earlier than you but
welcome to the party okay
so I'm intrigued by a culinary creation
of yours do you remember where you were
and what you were doing when you
invented the chili pizza sandwich and
can you walk us through step by Charlie
Pizza Sandwich
um you know Justine whose house I was in
when I invented this she's actually here
eating the wings with us just side note
um if you want to swing again yeah we do
we have a nice little side party over
here I would say
ours was left over chili so we
microwaved the chili I I we it was me in
Kentucky we put noodles in our chili one
piece of pizza is your bottom bun Two
Scoops heavy scoops of chili and then a
second pizza on top as the top it is
getting hotter I know that's the show
that's how it is it's gross I know yeah
and you start talking and it activates
and we make this whole thing because of
the oxygen yeah yeah clever right
[Music]
lines them up do you do that well shout
out to Chris he is in the building
usually he's never here but this time he
is the real skill yeah they actually
it's such a process that they go through
Chris and Noah just like keeled over
holding their stomachs like when you
open the door you feel like you're
walking in on something you shouldn't be
yeah it's through that elbow grease that
we put together this perfect hot sauce
Symphony that at least you're connecting
with on the first half
yeah okay oh I'm nervous so they can see
the chili flakes
so
I'm sure you're off wings are you off
chicken yeah actually I'll drink them
I bet yeah any sort of chicken sandwich
fried like whatever it all feels like
work to me you know of course but it
always follows me too you know like
you'll go to a restaurant and people
will want to send you wings right like
this is from the kitchen but you know
like that whole thing and it's all very
nice and it's all very sweet but it's
like you know it's fine you'd actually
think they'd know better
no but nobody thinks like that you know
what I mean there's just like there's
the chicken wing guy let's give him some
wings
yeah right yeah I guess I understand
that one wasn't that bad Chris I think
you
is it true that the Wardrobe department
at American Hustle had to make multiple
duplicate looks because you had a habit
of staining dresses snacking on Cool
Ranch Doritos between takes Cheeto dust
um yes well it was only one costume it
was a white dress and I feel really bad
I actually didn't know that until it
came out and that was very disrespectful
to cut to the costume Department
um yes that is true but an accident an
accident an accident you know I wasn't
like [__] you guys
I think also getting the second dress it
just encouraged me to I was like oh they
must have a million of these yeah you
know and then it just it was a domino
effect
Factor fiction you're hyperventilating
so intensely during the climactic scene
in mother that you actually dislocated a
rib I tore my diaphragm and um cracked
something in my chest and my diaphragm
yes wow or my top rib it still clicks to
this day
finally Liam Hemsworth made the claim
that you would intentionally eat meals
with either tuna or garlic before the
kissing scenes and Mockingjay confirm or
deny
it was not intentional
I was just like what I was eating
and then we'd kiss like he should just
you know get over it
[Music]
God I haven't had just like a glass of
milk
very sweet at first
[Music]
yeah yeah you catch that and then it
kind of leaves behind a lot of bite but
you're doing great oh yeah she's warm
she is warm she is warm oh and she's
warming up and building a little bit
she's building yeah just a sign of
what's to come oh but you're doing great
you're doing great okay so there's a
story I was reading about Jody Foster
who directed you in the beaver saying
that you'll look back on your career in
20 years time and be able to see a
pattern or see a connection between the
work and your life that was almost 15
years ago are you any closer to seeing
that sort of what it all means pattern
are you just as puzzled now as you were
back then no it
a little while ago I it was so
funny well I don't know if it made sense
but I definitely saw a pattern and me
playing
I guess parentified children yeah yeah
daughters that were kind of put in the
in the you know given responsibility
that was too much
at their time at the time and I guess
you know I left home when I was 14 and
I didn't you know I did kind of feel
like I had to be the parent so I guess
that that did kind of start making sense
and now I'm on to a whole different I
don't know what in the hell what does
this movie mean
what am I going to look back and be like
and then at the time I just really
wanted to date 20 year old
I love Buick Regals
I can feel it in like my gums like in
between my teeth yeah it starts finding
uh all the corners of the couch at this
point
I'm smoking
garlic
okay it's milk time
okay Chris
was that right at number seven properly
placed makes sense and I was kind of in
my head at the beginning I was like is
this show real right no I don't think
that anymore
ah growing up in the shadow of Churchill
Downs do you have any sort of Insider
internal calculus when deciding on which
horse is a good horse to place a bet on
I always like to look at the horses that
look like they're just like oh my God
you know the ones that are like the most
excited they're like get me out there
but I've never once won a race
you know
how would you describe your ideal
afternoon itinerary at Camp hijo
um oh my God at Camp Ohio
um
[Music]
oh god um do a little bit of horseback
riding and swim in the pond
um
I mean now there's like archery out
there and so sometimes I kind of do a
little bit of that which is embarrassing
I didn't even have to say that I didn't
have to admit it
um yeah swimming and horseback riding
and then finally which is a more hot be
anticipated Middle School field trip the
Louisville Slugger Museum or the Mega
Cavern oh my God the caves we went there
one time on a school field trip it was
sick well speaking of sick how we
feeling
um not sick okay hurt a little hurt
right right and it's always a show I
have to apologize for and a sauce that I
have to apologize for is always the next
one okay so this is oh this was the one
you warned me about this one yeah am I
allowed to say that okay it's all right
we can pull back I'm gonna coat with
milk
I'll follow suit
this is the bomb Beyond insanity
[Music]
oh good heaven yeah immediately
oh my God I know
I know and it doesn't stop again
I know I know
[Music]
hard to swallow
and then this is where I'll just say be
careful around the eyes oh my God I know
[Music]
oh my God
I saw someone do that on the show
you
Tick Tock I get the Instinct because it
just seems like there's more eyes
oh the other two are hotter
so this is me being your friend what you
just ate is the hottest most disgusting
hot sauce in the world okay nothing's
worse than that and the worst is over
I don't know what nothing else I know I
know I know I know it's just gross it's
just gross I get it I get it I get it
this is my face
oh
okay
it sounds
be careful that's a rental
[Music]
let's go so I was reading I was reading
that early on in your career you
arranged in a meeting with director Adam
McKay and showed up prepared with a
binder full of notes on both feral
movies reflecting on the catalog what in
your opinion is Will frail's greatest
cinematic Masterpiece and why I I did
have an actual binder I just meant how
ridiculous it was that I was like
18 and was like I'm gonna set up a
general meeting with Adam okay because I
really love his work you know I mean at
the time he wasn't like Adam okay he was
like Adam and k
um and so but I I just like
stuff that I loved about his movies
Anchorman I guess is like the obvious
one but
what's so great about elf is that when
you're making a movie you really don't
know you don't know how it's gonna turn
out yeah and so to be in a in an elf
costume in this green costume just like
merging around the city
I'm doing all of that and like
committing like sad
what's up is just um really admirable
I really respected a lot
I know
I'm trying to Exhale yeah
okay
all right are you going for the okay oh
whoa
I feel like I'm gonna die I know get it
[Music]
have you ever had anybody act like this
yeah
every hot one shoot is a unique unique
singular experience you know great
concept
thank you thank you but so they're all
their own unique path but you know what
as crazy as it gets on here I've always
seen something crazier you know what I
mean like I've seen some things
[Music]
not as bad as the bomb right
thank you for like warning me but I
guess but also
[__] you for like having us here I get
it I have it recovered it's not getting
better
is it getting any better for you I'm a
little bit yes because I'm a little bit
I'm on the other side of it a little bit
I'm on the other side of it
slightly
Georgie is my mascara waterproof
[Music]
it's actually everyone looks my whole
team
she's got it from here
how if it all did taking a break from
acting did it like strengthen or
undermine the enjoyment that you
purchased maybe a lot stronger out of
watching movies like removing yourself
from the business how if at all does
that like impact the own personal
enjoyment that you get out of watching
movies oh that's a good question
um I mean I don't I don't think so
because I I'm really I can always watch
movies like they're you know I've always
loved movies you can get lost in it
that's why I like reality TV
[Music]
so what if I just never finished that
Sunday because I love movies so much but
like it's a fourth wall thing I can't
finish the thought
[Music]
I will notice
you know great acting or like something
like wow I couldn't do that that's
that's amazing or you know what a
beautiful line but I don't really think
too much about
you know what's going on behind the
scenes unless it's like a boring movie
and then I start you know if I'm
noticing the camera work it's probably a
bad thing
okay is this one bad what do you mean
what do you mean by shaking out what are
you doing what do you mean what do you
what do you mean
[Music]
you don't have to
I recommend that you
I won't
I actually feel better
[Music]
we're in a mind trick
in just in time it's been an amazing
journey not through only the spice but
also through your career and to bring
things full circle from learning to skin
squirrels archery ballroom dancing and
Beyond can you explain learning to skin
squirrels because a lot of people won't
know oh right
Winter's Bone all part of the uh all
part of the character development all
part of the prep but I'm curious is
there a skill A specialized skill that
you've learned over the course of your
acting career that's been the most
valuable or transferable to your
everyday life
I learned how to pick locks on red
Sparrow I haven't used it but to know
that I could is cool
and I learned how to train Falcons for a
movie called Serena
not train them but
go like this
look at you Jennifer Lawrence taking on
the wings of death living to tell the
tale now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
thank you
did you eat it
you stopped after the bomb
[__]
oh
hello I'm camera guy Bill
foreign
[Applause]
who likes to sausage wings but I need a
brand new flavor to make these tastes
the same classic chili Maple that's
rolling down the line All Aboard it's
Canadian time would you look at that
coming around the bend a dash chili
frizzles from smoking and sauce is loose
runaway Caboose hotter than a babe on a
moose or a great northern staple try
that classic chill and maple made with
real maple syrup make you eat on your
stirrups
first and face got the Tweet hey Get on
Up and Dance on your feet first and face
got the sweet heat Get on Up and Dance
on your feet sweet and refreshing to
keep your senses guessing with the tiny
apple cider tons of bucking Rodeo Riders
whoa
hold it let's open some fun the hockey
Tonks Just Begun get permission from
your mom go to heatness.com
for a great northern staple try that
classic chili maple
[Music]
for a great northern Stapleton classic
chili maple
let's do it
hip-hop
y'all come back now
[Music]